est génial ma mère en fait je crois
qu'elle a aucun défaut elle aussi
toujours entre une très grande chaîne
voulait voir quelque chose et un froid
glacial et oublie moi quelque chose
invite les mots vieux je veux dire trois
plots pour nous un témoin un des cas et
à périers jarrier va la chercher à des
cahiers à périers j'arrive à faire bien
à limiter ma mère un des cas un terrier
charrier ses gestes sa manière de parler
de ce final non non le seul
ce fait jamais prendre c'est mon père tu
t'habilles en calédonien maintenant sais
pas pourquoi mais il ne veut pas que ce
soit une vie c'est quoi ce faire quoi ça
tu vas pas en picardie ce week-end parce
que je m'attendais d'entre nous
dépensions dans ma nouvelle pension ou
cette pension était merveilleuse
puis c'est là que j'ai rencontré jane
m
en fait j'ai géré baby gym et y en a
plein qui livre très heureux le plein de
quoi tant qu'on n'a pas essayé
tu peux pas savoir a toujours eu peur
des chevaux forcément marcher
vous les porterez l'ex l'anus mien le mr
yens
ça chante ma petite [ __ ] mais dites-moi
jeune homme vous prenez des médicaments
bon gars au moins t'es pas tous